España entra en el otoño tras la
temporada estival más calurosa desde por
lo menos el año 1961 que es cuando
oficialmente comenzaron a hacerse los
registros Un verano que se caracterizó
por tres horas de calor Que duraron en
total 42 días casi la mitad de lo que
dura la estación y Durante los cuales
murieron 83 personas a diario por exceso
de temperaturas pero por si algo se
caracterizó este verano fue por los
devastadores incendios que asolaron al
país
297.000 hectáreas de bosques Campos y
superficies quemadas como esta la Sierra
de la culebra en Zamora al oeste de
España donde el fuego calcinó casi 600
kilómetros cuadrados los peores a nivel
nacional y donde además fallecieron tres
personas la llegada del otoño
normalmente significa una bajada de
temperaturas y la llegada de la lluvia
sin embargo este año los expertos avisan
de que los próximos tres meses serán más
cálidos y secos de lo habitual algo que
preocupa en un país en el que las
reservas de agua para consumo están al
29% de su capacidad además en España
cada año se suman 1500 kilómetros
cuadrados de territorio con clima árido